hi guys so Johnny what is the Laughing
room so the Laughing room is a an art
installation that is space that's
designed to resemble a sitcom set with
an artificial intelligence algorithm
that listens to the participants in the
room and plays a laugh track when it
hears something that it deems funny can
you tell us about the artificial
intelligence kind of initiative that
you're looking at the artificial
intelligence project really comes out of
wanting to build bridges between MIT
libraries and Cambridge Public Library
to talk about the role of AI in our
lives so laughing room is the first of
what we hope will be a really exciting
series of events this year we're in a
space called the control room what's
that
so the control room is kind of the
companion piece to the laughing room the
laugh rooms over in the king of public
library and the control room is here at
MIT and the Hayden library and as you
can see behind us it is live to the
people who are into laughing right now
and then this is live to the algorithm
as it processes the information and
decides if it should play a laugh track
or not and so we're hoping that this
sort of becomes that critical piece of
this installation that talks about
privacy and talks about surveillance oh
my god guys we're live
Hannah how did you develop the AI so we
thought a lot about what we wanted to
include in the data set and we ended up
going with stand-up comedy routines
basically scraped from YouTube one thing
we did that was kind of interesting was
we made the data set solely of women and
people of color to kind of decrease the
amount of misogynist and racist values
that are AI would include it's one of
the big kind of questions in AI now
right is the bias ease of algorithms and
the prejudice that can kind of be
reproduced through algorithmic control
and there's this belief that like data
is objective and there's no such thing
as an objective right there's no such
thing as objective technology this
installation has so much to do with
integrating like technology and
artificial intelligence into everyday
life so on one side of the room you see
this regular living room type setup but
on the other you have monitors sound
boards every type of gadget that you can
think of it's a really dynamic space I
would say it likes knock-knock jokes